I'm Amy gates I am the director of our
almost to be data science and analytics
program we recently changed the name to
something that makes sense because
seriously what does ed olynyk's mean so
data science and analytics it's an
absolute pleasure to be here it's a
pleasure to host this it was a lot of
fun this entire group is awesome thank
you to Jared thank you to mark for
inviting me the first time learning
about this and thank you to heather
Connor for working our butt off to make
this happen and thank you to our
students and our volunteers thank you
guys for coming all right good stuff so
today we're going to talk about using
Network d3 and we're gonna use it in
conjunction with Twitter mining with
Association rule mining but our goal is
going to be to create an interactive
network visualization and so any of you
who have used d3 in the past you know
that d3 is well it is a steep learning
curve you could spend months and end up
with a bar graph you know so the good
news about this is that Network d3 is a
package that works in are so relatively
easy to use which is nice so let's take
a look and I'm going to go ahead and by
the way I just did this last summer it
was awesome I'm just I to put that out
there ok so why do we build networks
what are networks they're they're graphs
in a mathematical sense and that makes
them really robust because everything
that's true about a network is true
about a graph and vice versa which means
all the mathematics of graph theory can
be integrated into analyzing
understanding evaluating and looking at
networks so we look at networks when we
want to understand the relationship
between things
anything's the challenge is do we know
if there's a relationship can we define
that relationship do we understand what
the relationship is that we're trying to
visualize or analyze
so that we can put that together so in
my talk last year at DCR I went through
the Twitter part and the Association
rule mining part of this a little bit
I'm gonna fly through that part this
time but if you want a lot more on that
you can also look up last year's talk
this part I'm going to take a lot of
that but we're going to focus it in on
how do you then apply that and visualize
that interactively using Network III
okay so why would you want to build a
graph though what is the purpose of a
network and generally so a network is
considered an abstraction generally you
want to model things that are in
somewhere relationships what are the
applications they're limitless anytime
you have a relationship that you're
curious about so the one that always
comes to mind and I feel a little guilty
saying this much true anyway before the
last election there were two words that
occurred together in tweets possibly
more than any other two words that are
you know I'm not going to go there but
these two does anyone know what these
two words are does anyone remember two
words I'll give you a hint the first
ones email Hillary Clinton Hillary
Clinton an email and just Hillary or
Clinton because I said two words they
occurred together in so many tweets you
could build a word cloud or the whole
web and you can see these two words the
gigantic that's hold a story a story
that we're now living in right it's hold
an interesting story so you can use
networks to do all kinds of things and
that's everything from the spread of a
virus to analyzing terrorist networks to
electrical networks that are not for
terrorists so what's a network it's a
graph that's all network is it's made up
of nodes and edges the edges represent
relationships the nodes represent
anything you want them to that's the
beauty of building a network the hard
part is figuring out what the
relationship is and then formatting the
data so that you can make it something
that you can visualize something you can
analyze and understand
Oh basic graph theory and let's go
through this quickly so you get to the
good stuff graphs can be directed or
undirected there are many different ways
to represent graphs so humans look at
graphs like this computers they don't
they don't do this right they do things
that are numeric so one way to represent
a graph is using an adjacency matrix
this matrix is that graph there are
there are one of the same that's just
the computer view that's our view which
is I think it's kind of cool now for
network III it actually prefers
something a little bit easier on the
eyes something that looks more like this
where you define the edges we define the
nodes and then you can apply the network
d3 object to create the network okay so
we are going to focus on network d3 but
I don't want you guys to think that
that's the only way to do this there are
many different ways to create graphs in
networks and these are several of the
options and here are some decent links
as far as looking further into Network
III as well now we're going to Tarantino
it who's familiar with Tarantino thank
you guys seriously and if you're not
familiar with that either you have two
things now that you need to do when you
leave here okay these three
visualizations were created by using an
API to get Twitter data any hashtag you
want I used World News all the codes
there for that now when we took that
data because that date is a mess so many
people have scraped Twitter with an API
okay so when you scrape that and you you
can put in some different formats but
you've got to clean it up we also want
to clean it up and in this case we want
to put it in a transaction format so
that we can run it through Association
rule mining why do that because we're
looking to create a relationship between
words in tweets the question is are
there words and tweets that occur more
often together more often in general
this type of thing that's what
Association rule mining can do for us it
can tell us the words that occur more
more commonly we can then take that and
make that the relationship and then we
can visualize it so that's where we're
headed with this I did
with world news so I just did hashtag
World News and I just put the Twitter
out there to do its thing grab the data
cleaned it up did Association rule
mining on it which will see and
visualized by three different options so
here's one this is called the support
this is a network d3 vis it's
interactive this is on the web live so
it's wrapped up in an HTML wrapper which
I'll show you code for as well this
one's interesting because it created
actually two connected components to UM
tie disconnected components which is
kind of fun and you can then see when I
did the world news there's obviously
something was going on in Mexico there's
some intimations - drug united states
cartels that was one thing going on
world news was the hashtag and someone
so forth so this is one of them the
other one I did using confidence instead
of support as a measure got some really
different results which makes this fun
and makes it interesting to use
Association rule mining for this okay
so here's what's fun about Network d3
people like to play with it you can play
with it you can explore and you can look
at it you can ask yourself questions
about it like are there clusters are
there families
what's the diameter what's the node
degree and you can even integrate that
into the network d3 object as you wish
so in the spirit of Tarantino that's did
you close my thing it closed my thing
why would it do that oh no now I'm gonna
have to search for it while showing you
guys my screen I didn't put that picture
of myself but someone else did that
[Laughter]
okey-dokey there we go it's fine okay
let's go back right where we were and
pretend that didn't happen
okie dokie yeah so that's where we're
headed so let's get there yeah sorry
about that does that yeah let's skip to
the good stuff so a couple of measures
that you can utilize when you're
evaluating networks you can use a
measure call between this and between
this will give you a higher measure if
the node has more of a communica Tory
effect to the other nodes in the network
so you can tell here that node 4 if you
were to cut that node you would actually
disrupt disrupt communication maximally
in this network so that's interesting
it's interesting if you're trying to
whole you know put a stop to a viral
outbreak it's interesting if you're
trying to put a stop to a terrorist
network all right it's sometimes you
care about between this and a graph or
in a network so that's one of the
measures one of the other measures that
we see a lot is the notion of
communities so if you were to use
Facebook data and create networks of
Facebook data you would discover that
the relationship is who's friends with
whom and then you would see clusters of
friends and then you'd see connectors
those connectors have the highest
betweenness measure and so that's
interesting as well depending on if you
wanted to communicate or disseminate
information so network communities are
also great interest when you're
evaluating and this this was there it is
again
a terrorist network and sometimes you'll
ask the question okay we have a
terrorist note we're going to trying to
take out one of the core elements which
one should we take out first because
every time we do something it costs
money and that's questionable results so
we want to make sure that you know we're
least picking the right one okay so
networking is everywhere and it can be
applied to pretty much anything even
biological systems and so finally let's
get to the good stuff okay so how do we
do this in our what are the steps we're
going to go through here first of all
you need to get a Twitter Developer
account if you want to use my code you
can run this coding
these slides once you get a Twitter dev
account you will get a bunch of keys and
tokens and the name of your firstborn
child and you will use that information
to essentially access Twitter so what's
kind of cool is that when Mark Davis
talked he talked about a api's this is
an API for Twitter and in this case
we're accessing Twitter using the oath
using all the tokens that we get and so
on these are the libraries that I used
the ones in bold were directly used the
ones not in bold I played around with
but left them because I think people
appreciate that okay so here's the build
the environment part of this this is
where I set up the oath so set up
Twitter oath sets up the API and then
the Twitter and then search Twitter and
you'll notice I searched for world news
I gave it a date I gave it the number of
tweets I pulled that search object into
a data frame and then I want to take a
look at it just to make sure that I'm
grabbing that first tweet so the search
D F text feel like this [ __ ] function
where's the beeper thing it's okay you
guys don't I'm talking about okay here's
the text moon tweets what you end up
getting is a data frame so this is one
column of that data frame there are
other columns too like geo tags like
dates like whether it was retweeted
there's a ton of information in every
single tweet this is part of it now the
trick of Association rule mining in this
case is you don't want to lose the tweet
this is not the same as bag-of-words for
people who are familiar with that
I'm not taking all the words in every
single tweet and just simply creating a
vocabulary of words with frequencies
that's certainly one way to do it in
text mining what I want to do here is I
want to keep each tweet I don't want to
lose that context and I want to ask the
question what are people tweeting about
most often in each given tweet so that's
that's an interesting question now I'm
gonna do this part fast because again
this this was done last year a little
bit so here's a single tweet I can
access it here's the part where I build
the transaction data from the tweets
here's what it starts to look like so
instead of now having tweets I start to
have individual words it's still very
dirty and I have to clean it a lot so
here's all the cleaning
it's I'm not gonna read your code but
it's there for later
okay now I'm looking a little better I
still have things one tweet at a time
which is good once I have it in that
state that state I can read it in as a
transaction data so you'll notice that
this this is for my students too this is
not record data guys though I'm hoping
you guys know this now this is not
record data
this is transaction data every row is a
bunch of tokens in this case which are
words so there's no columns per se which
represent variables and the rows can go
on as long as you want them to that's
the difference between transaction
versus record data once you have it you
can read it in do some fancy footwork
with using a rules the a priori method
this is all Association rule mining and
are you can choose your support your
confidence your lift if you wish and
things like this and eventually you can
sort the rules here's what we're trying
to get to so all that stuff everything I
just covered that's a little bit of
review of last year here's what we're
trying to get to because what we want to
have is a relationship between words we
want to see that lives and world news
are related to each other we want to see
that lives matter are related to each
other things like this because we've now
created determined a relationship now we
can build a network so you can't just
plop record data into a network it won't
work you have to determine what is the
relationship you want to show or or
visualize from here and this is a
17-hour error just in case you run into
this with air rules this will fix it
just FYI in this case what we want to do
now is we want to build the things we
need for the network d3 object so
network d3 is going to expect things
from us it's gonna want to know what are
the nodes what are their IDs what are
they called what are the edges which
node goes to which node how do we want
to color them how long do you want the
edges
to be how fat do you want the edges to
be want to know all this information
from us so right now at this moment like
all of data science we're gonna spend
90% of our time formatting it and
getting it ready right and then five
seconds enjoying it but she reminds me
of something else as well okay yeah
thank you for that okay so somebody just
got it over there okay converting our
rules to a data frame is our first step
once we have our rules in the data frame
format we can start altering that data
frame to represent the edges that we
need for Network t3 and the nodes that
we're going to need for network t3 so
it's basically a process of massaging or
data into the format that we need it to
get into okay so here's where we are now
this is a much better spot we actually
have a from node a to node and some kind
of options for weights again I won't
have time to go into what support
confidence and lift means I wish I did I
did that last year so if you're
wondering just watch that that talk and
that's what I did that a lot that was
the whole focus of the talk so now as I
take my word for it these are three
different measures I can use to weight
the the edges I can weight the nodes I
don't have to weight anything it's it's
really up to you what you want to do
with your network okay now I'm finally
gonna build the edges because I use
Association rule mining I have sort of
three different sets of rules that are
of interest when you do Association rule
mining with a new sort by support you
get a different set of associations than
you do when you sort by confidence or
when you sort by lift so just as a quick
example support is how often words occur
together in a data set confidence is how
often they occur together so it's going
to give you some different results so in
this case what I'm doing here in this
code is I'm taking different columns out
of that data set because I want to see
all three I want to see what they look
like and I'm gonna go one at a time I
don't have a loop here so if you were to
do this
you'd have to either unhatched AG or put
in a loop and I'm gonna then finally
build the edge list no this is where
understanding what an object expects is
just it's part of it you have to do it
so in this case Network d3 needs
something called a node ID it needs a
source node it needs a target node and
the IDS have to start at zero whereas we
know that our starts with one so we have
to make a couple of adjustments so that
we're again shifting our data over to
what network d3 is going to expect and
that's what all this does essentially
and here's the result so now I have a
source name
that's one node I have a target name
that's the node that it's going to so
now I have an edge between Americas and
countries I'm gonna have an edge between
Americas and experts and so on and so
forth so this is essentially defining
that edge list I have a weight and I
have now source IDs and target IDs which
network III requires I need to build the
nodes as well I use I graph and then
also used I graph to update the IDs
so that they were all subtracted by one
so that Network d3 is happy in the end
you end up with a nice node list so this
is the name of all the nodes the degree
what is a node degree it's how many
edges are incident to that node so we
want that information to and you can use
that information to affect the size of
the node if you want as well which is
interesting to look at and so on and so
forth so what we've created now is we
have a list of edges or an edge list and
we have a list of nodes so if you pause
for a second you think where do we start
we started with the Twitter API that's
where we began all we did was grab
tweets and then cleaning and cleaning
and formatting and data frame and then
building an edge list to finding a
relationship using Association rule
mining to create that relationship all
the way to were a point where we have we
have something like this now in the past
when I've seen people talk about
building networks this is where they
start I
feel like it leaves out all the part of
what you have to do to get here that's
90 percent of what you have to do the
rest of it's just a fun bit so here is
the final part this is the network d3
object to me that's very very exciting
so the object is made up of all kinds of
attributes right we need to define the
links and we did that we have an edge
list those are the links or the edges we
need to define the nodes we did that we
built a node list so we're gonna use
that we have a source that's our source
ID we have a target that's our target ID
we went through and actually built all
of these things so that we could create
this object we have value equals weight
and you can set the weight to be the
confidence the lift
the support or some function of those
three you lot of options there and then
finally we can affect some of the other
things one more thing I'll note here oh
my gosh you guys in Lanikai oops my bad
anyway that's the object I will note one
more thing before I stop talking you
guys are giving me that look like you
need to stop talking so Network d3 is
jaw it has a JavaScript option that
allows you to pull in functionality from
value and effect the length and width
and so on of your nodes this is how this
works so I'm done and let's take a final
look at just Network d3
[Applause]